firstly want to ask you about though was
this story that was going around there's
something called the chalice cannabis
festival oh yeah yeah and you had a gig
there and it always seemed like a pro to
me we've done a bunch of things together
you're always on time or early you
showed up for the cannabis festival 90
minutes late now I guess we gonna be
late for anything it should be the
cannabis chalice festival whatever but
what happened there well first of all
they was so hot I didn't even know I was
late first of all is that true when you
did show up what would they like that
you were 90 minutes 90 minutes and it
was like yo man when his Q performing I
said perform it tomorrow You shant told
him I already did what my fault it
wasn't my fault look at the janky
promoters we had had we had a car and
the car broke down on the side of the
road nine and we it was 90 minutes late
because of the wind out there it was
about to blow the stage over so right I
was a big hold up so we were already
late and the other Genki promoter
couldn't find us on the side of the road
so we had to call over you called uber
you called it uber to get to your gig to
perform on time yeah you know a cool
lady in the minivan just drove us right
to the city I wish I'd been there to see
you get into a minivan that would have
been great trust me I've been in a few
it was Kody just to see her look back
and say thank you yes Mimi just drive
let's drive
you